[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute sind wir allerdings
wieder in meiner kochwelt denn heute
wird wieder gekocht wir bekommen heute
ein bisschen besucht und wir machen
heute eines unserer lieblings
hauptgerichte neben der lasagne zum
beispiel und wahr machen wir heute
spaghetti bolognese und die mache ich
heute relativ klassisch mit etwas gemüse
und fleisch und das ist auch seine
lieblingsspeise von meinem mann der
übrigens gleich noch zu mir holen muss
aber heute ich auch die karriere damit
dabei unsere freundinnen
denn murat dabei unterstützt ein
besserer kamera wand zu werden
ich würde sagen ich zeige euch mal die
zutaten wir machen heute eine relativ
große portionen weil wir alles sehr viel
hunger haben und ich zeige euch das
jetzt einfach mal auf und starten liegt
und wir brauchen wir etwas olivenöl dann
brauchen wir noch zwei zwiebeln da
können wir jetzt entweder zwei große und
nehmen
ich habe es eine große und eine kleine
hier noch eine knoblauchzehe etwas
tomatenmark das sind etwa zwei esslöffel
zwei karotten zwei stangen
staudensellerie und zwar freaks stauben
destillerie so aus also das kriegt man
so am stück im supermarkt oder auf markt
und damit einfach zwei stück abgerissen
und starten sie natürlich schmeckt zum
beispiel auch ganz gut ins minuten kann
man gar nicht glauben weil es irgendwie
so total aromatischen wirklich schmeckt
aber ich finds richtig lecker grad so
schönes motiv
dann brauchen wir natürlich hackfleisch
ich habe jetzt hier in rindfleisch am
stück und werdet es dann gleich zu
hackfleisch verarbeiten und zeigt oder
gleich wie das geht
hier habe ich zwei dosentomaten und zwar
sind es schon fein gehackten tomaten
stücke die nehme ich immer gerne weil
wir hier in deutschland keine so
aromatischen tomaten bekommen und die
tomaten aus der dose bekomme ich zu
jeder jahreszeit und kann deswegen immer
darauf zurückgreifen und habe sie
einfach immer im haus
wir brauchen dann noch etwas petersilie
die muss nicht sein ist optional
und dann noch ein paar gewürze und zwar
nehme ich später ein lorbeerblatt einen
teelöffel currypulver einen teelöffel
oregano oder ein esslöffel sogar ich
nehme auch noch etwas chili da können da
selber abstimmen wie viel ihr möchtet
einen esslöffel milch so yoga oder
oregon
ja da streiten wir immer darum ich
vergebe oregano majoran keine ahnung ihr
könnt ihr mal sagen wir jetzt
aussprechen einfach mal runter schreiben
aber nicht einfach oregano schreiben
sondern gleich mit doppel- oder
doppelter oder so dass wir es erkennen
und ich mache übrigens heute meinen
hackfleisch selber und zwar war er
gerade vor kurzem mit dieser skandal mit
dem pferdefleisch zum beispiel im
hackfleisch drin und ich finde man
sollte einfach auch mal wissen wie
hackfleisch selber wie man das eben
selber machen kann und ich mache es auch
ganz gern selber jetzt nicht nur weil
ich meine metzger nicht vertraue ich
habe einen metzger meines vertrauens und
kauft da auch gern mein hackfleisch und
mein ganzes fleisch aber ich finde es
auch wichtig weil ich so zum beispiel
auch bestimmen kann was für fleischig
nehmen ich nehme jetzt zum beispiel nur
ein rindfleisch aber ich nehme auch ganz
gern rind und lamm und mittels und macht
damit zum beispiel leckere frikadellen
oder lahmacun
kapitel und war kann ich einfach selber
bestimmen wie das fleisch gemischt
werden soll
wer sich da noch besser auskennt kann
auch so selber bestimmen wie zum
beispiel der fettgehalt sein sollen und
so kann man es einfach selber machen und
ich bitte es auch sagen bevor ich jetzt
hier mein gemüse vorbereitet werde ich
mich um sie kümmern
damit dieses hackfleisch ist in meinem
fleischwolf zerkleinern kann muss ich
jetzt erstmal in kleine stücke schneiden
und das mache ich jetzt einfach thema
kurz
[Musik]
und dann können wir das fleisch durch
125 durchleben ich habe jetzt einen ganz
feinen aufsatz man könnte auch etwas
gröber machen
mein hackfleisch vorbereitet und jetzt
werde ich das in meiner pfanne mit etwas
olivenöl an kosten und in der
zwischenzeit dann mich um das gemüse
können und ich fange schon machen
gemeint sein zu dürfen macht jetzt
einfach mal einen roman olivenöl es
heißt es riecht man und jetzt kann ich
dir das fleisch wein
jetzt glaube ich gar nicht alle weil
meine pfanne recht klein ist
ach komm ich her
und jetzt lassen wir das war einfach
schön anbraten und ist für das
gelegentlich durch
[Applaus]
mein hackfleisch ist schon angebracht
und sieht jetzt hier und jetzt kommen da
die zwiebelwürfel und die knoblauch
würfel mit dazu die zone ist wirklich
sehr klein aber ich hab' geraten und
keine anderen das war jetzt notfall
geschirr weil ich habe meine alten weg
gegeben habe wegen der induktionsherd
klasse jetzt kurz weiter braten und wird
schon mal karotten und sellerie einfach
auch fein würfeln
[Musik]
dann gebe ich die karotten dürfen hier
mit rein
ihr könnt da wenn ihr es nicht ganz
klassisch macht auch gerne andere gemüse
mit rein geben
ihr könnt die karotten auch in großen
stücken lassen und später wieder aus
ressource herausfischen
so macht jetzt eine freundin von uns
immer weil sie nur hat bleibt dann in
das opel haben will dir da eigentlich
nur um den geschmack aber ich weiß dass
immer gern bin ich mag es gemütlich so
dann auch noch sellerie und dann kommen
noch die sellerie würfel mit dazu
[Musik]
wirkliches gemüse so ein bisschen mit
anbraten und dann gebe ich auf das
tomatenmark mit ein das lasse ich auch
immer gerne etwas mit braten
bevor ich dann mit den tomaten ablöschen
und dann können die tomaten aus der dose
mitschreiben schaltet auch gleich die
hits darunter so baldauf kocht
und wenn ihr merkt es ist jetzt so
dickflüssig nimmt da einfach die tomaten
und damit dass davon auch nicht
verschwendet wird ewig da so etwa die
hälfte oder einem viertel davon völlig
mit wasser und schützt damit dazu uns
dann wird das kurzprogramm hört
das magazin nicht ganz vermischt
deswegen stehe ich jetzt noch zu hell
aus und jetzt gebe ich hier noch das
lorbeerblatt mit dazu und die restlichen
gewürze und lasse dann einfach nicht
[Musik]
was natürlich auch nicht fehlen darf ist
pfeffer den habe ich vorhin vergessen zu
erwähnen
und natürlich auch etwas falsch
hier gibt es jetzt den deckel drauf und
lass die soße für mindestens 20 minuten
kochen besser noch 30 minuten
aber ich habe sogar eine freundin die
liste ihrer polonaise fünf stunden lang
kochen
aber ich finde die schmeckt auch schon
nach einer halben stunde richtig lecker
nudelwasser kocht jetzt schon wir haben
es schon kinder gestellt das wird jetzt
natürlich auch gezahlten entschuldigung
du auch noch ein bisschen ein bisschen
makaber aber wer war ganz schön viel
nudeln und deswegen bis gut sein
jetzt machen wir das auch machen wir
einfach so machen wenn ich auf der
herdplatte und einmal reinschmeißen also
nicht schmeißen rein wegen wird was
nicht mal so und mal noch ein paar nicht
alle aber so
hier nochmal die hälfte ok und so dass
es ungefähr für sechs personen reinlegen
und gleich mit der wegfall über topfit
ganz heiß
[Musik]
und wer kennt das nicht auch die nudeln
kochen ja gerne mal über und ich werde
jetzt damit die nudeln schneller kochen
kann man ja wieder den topf druck setzen
aber ihr kennt es ja dann würde es jetzt
gleich über kochen und deswegen benutzen
wir jetzt einfach diese kopf blume ihr
habt ja schon ganz oft bei mir hier im
hintergrund gesehen und mich gefragt was
ist das was ist das und es kommt hierbei
nur die kochen impressum einsatz kann
ich sogar ein bisschen runter schalten
wir brauchen jetzt nicht mehr die volle
leistung und jetzt wird gleich hier das
sehen wie es koch dann einfach hier oben
rein und kommt nicht mehr über und jetzt
lassen wir einfach qsc nudeln al dente
kochen also bissfest und setzte dann
abgießen die soße ist auch gleich fertig
da habe ich jetzt einfach noch die
petersilie mit rein und da nehme ich
immer ganz gerne frische kräuter auch
gerne basilikum einfach was ihr da die
nudeln sind jetzt al dente und ich warte
jetzt ab gießen und dafür nämlich
einfach den sieg denn kennt er darf so
schön platzsparend den kann man einfach
so aufklappen oder eben wieder zuklappen
und jetzt werden wir kurz die nudeln
abgießen gehen und da ist ganz wichtig
dass wir immer vom körper weg fließen
also nicht zu euch gießen da könnt euch
echt verbrennen sondern so wie hier vom
körper weg ganz vorsichtig was ich dann
wieder
und dann können die nudeln wieder in den
topf zurück dass sie nicht kalt werden
das gefühl ich später ok ich gebe hier
noch ein bisschen olivenöl rein damit
die nudel nicht anderen das leben
man könnte sich aber auch ein bisschen
was vom rudel seidel wasser aufheben und
das dann mit rein geben das geht dann
auch aber ja was habt ihr eigentlich
darf so viele tipps
also meine freundin hat es in
nudelwasser gemacht aber ich finde und
werden sie immer so ein bisschen matsch
ich meiner mama nimmt immer butter ist
schmeckt natürlich sehr gut aber es ist
immer sehr viel futter
deswegen sind unternehmer ist er fertig
und ich nehme immer oliven irgendwas
dazu passt und dann kann über die nudeln
servieren
das kam damals der große papa vorzügen
für den papa okay okay
papa du kriegst nur so viel ich das
reichte los weil sie so wenig aus
[Musik]
ich muss zu wenig die polonaise schmeckt
heute etwas anders weil ich heute
petersilie genommen hat statt basilikum
basilikum macht es natürlich etwas
italienisch und was natürlich immer mit
drauf muss ist frisch geriebener
parmesan der darf bei uns nie fehlen
ja das gibt es wirklich hasse ich glaube
mit dem richtig guten parmesan kann man
rasch mit gold vergleichen oder und
deswegen ist so praktisch unsere ja eine
unserer lieblingsspeisen sag ich mal
weil wir haben echt mehrere bestandteil
natur darf gleich probieren und wir
setzen uns gleich alle an den tisch und
verspeisen sie ist dann alles schön das
rezept gibt es natürlich zum nachlesen
auf sell izmir das blog de ich glaube
samira ist jetzt schon sagt die wird
nicht mit am tisch sitzen
gut also wir lassen es uns jetzt weiter
schmecken und putzen dann erstmal die
küche viel spaß beim nachkochen und wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder im
anschluss verlinke ich euch übrigens
wieder ein video
[Musik]